there's nowhere to run and very few
places to hide in the besieged city of
cebra donetsk
they cook food on fires in the open
power and running water stopped weeks
ago
but it's always done within easy reach
of their underground shelter
to descend down here is to enter a truly
grim dank and perpetually dark place
desperation and despair stalk the
concrete corridors and disease runs riot
there's a shame here amongst the
residents a real embarrassment about
being reduced to this
there are nearly a hundred people living
on top of one another twenty feet
underground the only place they feel
offers them some chance of survival from
the bombings above
they've had an outbreak of tuberculosis
people have caught pneumonia in here
hygiene's obviously extremely hard in
these terribly cramped conditions and we
hear constant coughing and wretching
sheets of cardboard are used as
separation but they offer scant privacy
and all this is all they have salvaged
from their lives
life has a post-apocalyptic feel about
it down here but still some display a
steely determination to come through
this
[Music]
i must
survive i don't think about those
challenges bombings explosions and so on
and so forth i just wanna i just
have to or even musk
must survive
there's a half hour when the generators
switched on and they have power there's
a rush to charge phones used for light
and to take the chance to maintain some
self-care
but it also means they can pump water
and stock up on supplies
tanya goes round the shelter telling
everyone this is the final opportunity
to get out of several
this is the last chance for evacuation
she says think about it but no one here
is ready to flee their home city despite
the obvious dangers many here have had
access only to russian propaganda and
believe they're liberating them
there's intense bombardment russian
troops are at the city gates and on the
cusp of circling it
it seems only a matter of time
this has been going on
this has been going on all morning there
are lots and lots of residents still
living here a lot of them old people and
having to run in and out of this just to
cook or to fetch water it is relentless
the russians are bombing street by
street in their efforts to capture this
city blasting houses and homes which
stand in their path they have the
momentum now
and the destruction is immense
taking sevra donetsk would mean the
whole of the lehansk region falls to
russian control
maria and ivan have lived here all their
married lives now they're outdoor
kitchens amongst the world's most
dangerous
they've just got food scraps and blame
both sides for targeting civilians
foreign
[Music]
uh
come on come on says maria this is so
hard for the elderly who don't
understand why there's a war over
donbass at all
maria urges ivan to clear space for us
to shelter they're more worried about
our safety
this is what their days are like now
dodging explosions and separated from
their grandchildren
[Music]
and they feel they've been badly let
down by their city leaders
[Applause]
so far they've been lucky but they've
come close
but the real hurt is in the family
separation
the city already looks smashed to pieces
but there are thousands of civilians
still inside and the russians show no
signs of stopping their barrage yet
alex crawford sky news inside sevra
donetsk in the donbass eastern ukraine